I'm gonna sleep just so you know you
could have had sex tonight good pilot
for Everybody Loves Raymond I've gotten
picked up and I was stressing over the
name so I remember being in the dressing
room waiting to do my stand-up and
writing alternate names for Everybody
Loves Raymond
thankfully those other titles never made
the cut
Raymond's tree like the family Tony yeah
and then one of them was um Raymond um
comma Raymond and you know I pitched it
all to CBS and none of it stuck ray
looks completely different in his new
Netflix movie a paddle tip is what
Michael has incurable okay that's a
question he and Mark Duplass play misfit
friends who deal with a diagnosis of
terminal cancer the fact that we were
going to be able to just kind of
improvise here and you know outline it
and just feel it it was scary but very
exciting you needed the money - I did
need the money he was going he was
having a hot tough time so I was like
hey come be in an independent film and
make a lot of money my trailer was a
chair and Mark is making that money
snagging himself a role in the upcoming
Apple series set in the world of morning
TV the cast is a dream cast of you know
Reese Witherspoon and Jennifer Aniston
and Steve Carell and Billy Crudup I play
the producer of the show that everyone's
involved with and he's you know sort of
perennially stressed out and trying to
keep it all together which is a lot like
Ray Romano yeah
[Music]